- [Narrator] In the '80s when
lots of people were playing
arcade games like Pac Man,
Donkey Kong and Frogger,
this is what they were
playing in Soviet Russia.
(game beeping)
- [Narrator] That's Alexander,
he runs the Museum of Soviet
Arcade Machines in St. Petersburg Russia.
- [Narrator] Unlike their
western counterparts,
the games weren't just for fun.
- [Narrator] The point of the
games was training for the
Soviet Army, building
skills like reasoning,
hand-eye coordination and marksmanship.
- [Narrator] All the Soviet
arcade games were built in
military factories using
leftover parts from weapons,
refrigerators, calculators
and other items.
- [Narrator] But now,
decades after the fall
of the Soviet Union.
(upbeat music)